fittingly for a show about the future
Futurama was ahead of the curve in all
sorts of ways who would have thought
that a world full of alcohol powered
robots and smella Scopes would end up
resembling our own here's all the times
that Futurama freakishly predicted the
future one of the most ubiquitous pieces
of technology in the world Futurama is
the wrist mounted computer though they
never get an official name Leela
typically refers to hers as a wrist
thingy Leela has used her wrist thingy
as a phone a clock a remote control for
the Planet Express ship and basically
everything else ever since the days of
the Jetsons we have longed for
wristwatch computers but when Futurama
premiered they were still a distant
dream
the closest thing we had at the time was
Samsung's SP hwp 10 a wrist mounted cell
phone that weighed 50 grams and had a
battery life of 90 minutes over the past
few years though this dream has more or
less come true with smartwatches like
the Apple watch that can now approximate
many of the functions of the smartphone
of course unlike Leela's wrist thingy
the Apple watch can't record someone
rapping and then analyze the success
rate of their rhyme busting in many ways
our modern world doesn't look all that
different from 1999 when Futurama first
premiered most of our technological
progress in the past two decades has
been in the realm of computers rather
than jetpacks and flying cars however we
have had one major change to the skies
of our cities and that's the development
of quadcopter drones in recent years
technology surrounding unmanned aerial
vehicles has progressed by leaps and
bounds leading to widespread
availability of cheap quadcopter drones
for pretty much anyone who wants one
believe it or not Futurama kind of
called this one floating camera drones
appear all throughout Futurama in lieu
of human camera operators however no one
in the Futurama verse figured out that
the drones can be used to make
deliveries it's a good thing too or else
the Planet Express crew might be out of
a job in the film the lesser of two
evils fry Leela and Bender visit pastor
Rama a theme park that's supposed to
recreate late 20th early 21st century in
New York it's not exactly accurate the
only clearly predictive element of
scenery is the marquee at the theater
which advertises star wars 9 Yoda's bar
mitzva
the lesser of two evils first aired the
newest Star Wars film to come out with
Star Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace
and given how poorly received that film
was the thought that we'd eventually get
an episode 9 was far from certain this
isn't the only time that when a Futurama
z-- joke movies ended up actually
getting made in the episode a fish full
of dollars fry meets the head of Pamela
Anderson who tells him that she started
Baywatch the movie
hello fry remember me from Baywatch the
movie it was the first movie to be shot
entirely in slow motion 18 years later
at the at Racal Baywatch film did hit
theaters with Anderson providing a cameo
in the world of Futurama robots like
bender are powered by alcohol out of all
the whacky elements from Futurama
setting that might actually come to pass
there's no way we're going to actually
get machines that run on beer Willy we
present to you the newest innovation and
automotive fuel beer created by New
Zealand brewery DV export brute ro Liam
is an ethanol fuel made from the yeast
and grain waste products left over by
the brewing process okay so it's not
actually beer but finding leftover bits
of biomass from other industries and
processing those waste products into
ethanol fuel could be the future of
biofuels it's frequently less work and
according to some reports growing crops
explicitly for use as biofuels could
contribute to food shortages so if you
want the full Futurama experience of
sharing a beer with one of your robot
friends it turns out that finding the
fuel is easy the hard part is finding a
robot that runs on diesel you could
always try the big dog robot that was
developed by Boston Dynamics back in
2005 which does have a gas-powered
engine just don't make the mistake of
sharing a beer with your flesh-and-blood
dog
- even though Futurama takes place in
the 31st century most of the prominent
celebrities in that world are the same
ones we have today however in most cases
all that's left of them is their heads
which are kept alive in jars full of
liquid we might not have cracked the
science of preserving heads in jars yet
in our century but through new advances
in computer-generated imagery we are
fast approaching a world where
celebrities never die ever since the
debut of the infamous
Tupac hologram the genie has been out of
the bottle in terms of using technology
to virtually resurrect the dead in Star
Wars rogue one motion capture in CGI
meant that the late Peter Cushing could
reprise his role as grand moff tarkin
and a digitally D aged Carrie Fisher
could make a cameo as Leia after Paul
Walker's unexpected death during the
production of Furious 7 a mixture of
visual effects techniques recreated his
likeness for the last few scenes he was
unavailable to film an especially
controversial recent example is the
virtual casting of James Dean in the
film finding Jack say what you want
about preserving a head in a jar at
least in that case dead celebrity can
voice an opinion
Futurama wasn't the first work of
science fiction deposit using computers
to create immersive simulated
experiences movies like Neuromancer and
films like brainstorm told stories about
virtual reality decades earlier
however Futurama seems to be the first
work of fiction to predict how quickly
this technology would be used to create
and gamify totally mundane experiences
Futurama first presented its take on VR
in the episode the series is landed when
the Planet Express crew visits an
amusement park on the moon to deliver a
package they swing by a video arcade to
play some games first we see someone
playing skee-ball
then we see someone playing virtual
skee-ball and finally we see Amy playing
virtual skee-ball wearing a VR headset
and just sitting in a chair a couple of
decades later a parrot games shockingly
similar to virtual virtual skee-ball
came along in the form of job simulator
and its sequel vacation simulator these
comedic games use the magic of oculus
rift technology to create immersive
simulations of completely mundane
situations hello human welcome to an
accurate simulation of this worker these
sorts of tongue-in-cheek games obviously
aren't the only thing that virtual
reality is being used for but they do
speak to a larger cultural trend that
Futurama predicted no technology no
matter how inspiring can keep blowing
our minds forever eventually everything
becomes a punchline Professor Farnsworth
has created a lot of iconic inventions
over the years such as the kilometre the
what-if machine and the thing longer
perhaps his most memorable
is the smella scope which allows its
users to smell objects at an
astronomical scale as Farnsworth puts it
that's my prize-winning smell-a-scope if
a dog craps anywhere in the universe
you can bet I won't be out of the loop
as silly as this device may be it's not
too far off from a real-world invention
known as the nasal Ranger
unfortunately the nasal Ranger can't
smell objects at long ranges if you
aren't in the same space as a given odor
with actual bits of it entering your
nose
there's no way to smell it however this
field effect ometer can be used by a
trained operator to quantify just how
strong a smell really is the nasal
Ranger allows its user to inhale ambient
air filtered to varying degrees as
determined by an adjustable dial by
changing the tolerance of the filters an
operator can discover just how much a
stench needs to be diluted before it's
no longer offensive according to a
segment of modern marvels all about the
nasal Ranger any scent that can still be
detected when one part of it is diluted
with 15 parts clean air is a nuisance as
cool as the nasal Ranger is we're a
little disappointed that its creators
opted to measure stinkiness with
dilution ratios instead of the smella
scopes far more scientifically exact
funko meter in I dated a robot Frey
discovers a service that sells robotic
companions with the personalities and
appearances of celebrities but shortly
after Frey purchases one based on Lucy
Liu's circa 2003 he learns a terrible
truth this company is programming its
robots by kidnapping real celebrity
heads and forcibly scanning their brains
in the end Frey rescues the real Lucy
Liu and the other kidnapped celebrity
heads finally he destroys his unlawfully
acquired liubot and keeping with actual
Lucy Liu's wishes though realistic
robots are still a ways off we're
getting closer every year one company
recently released a version of a doll
with a customizable robotic head capable
of speech and limited movements as a
joke
comedian Whitney Cummings purchased one
customized to look like herself and
incorporated the robot into a stand-up
special perhaps predictably shortly
thereafter the company real badhak
supported a deluge of requests from
customers for
Whitney Cummings robots however real ba
Tech's rejected these requests since
they didn't own Cummings likeness
another form of entertainment this
episode unintentionally predicts is deep
fake adult entertainment the latest
trend on many adult streaming sites are
videos that have been edited with facial
replacement technology to impose
celebrities faces onto the bodies of
adult actors without the consent of the
given celebrities when the crew goes to
watch all my circuits the movie in the
episode raging vendor we see the movies
have changed a bit since the 21st
century as robot businessman Calculon is
finishing some paperwork he receives a
phone call alerting him that a fight
scene has broken out at the
special-effects warehouse an announcer
asks the audience to choose what happens
next
if you want Calculon to race to the
laser gun battle in his hover Ferrari
press 1 if you want Calculon to double
check his paperwork press 2 the audience
selects two and Calculon spends the next
few minutes sitting at his desk flipping
through papers the promise of
interactive films has been on the
frontier of cinema for decades the first
interactive movie was the 1967 Czech
film Kino automat but surprisingly few
films have followed in Kino automats
tracks since the premiere of raging
bender much of the hype around
interactive films has been realized the
narrative-driven video games like her
story the Stanley parable or the work of
telltale games black mirror recently
experimented with the potential of
streaming services to create interactive
fiction with its mind-bending special
Bandersnatch it was like many
interactive movies praised for its
novelty but criticized for not having
much depth beyond its high concept one
instance of Futurama is uncanny
prescience came in an episode that ended
up predicting not a technological trend
but a news story in the lesser of two
evils Leela fry and Bender find
themselves at the Miss Universe pageant
as the crew is watching the show one of
Leela's exes Zapp Brannigan is
presenting the award when Zapp notices
Leela as he opens the envelope he calls
out her name and surprise however the
pageant staff miss interprets this as
Zapp announcing Leela as the winner so
they drag her onstage and give her
flowers in a crown moments later Zapp
corrects the error and Leela is stripped
of her crown
flowers to be given to the actual winner
in 2015 the actual Miss Universe pageant
had a mix-up of its own moments after
Miss Colombia was crowned Miss Universe
comedian Steve Harvey who is in charge
of presenting the winner realized that
he had misread the piece of paper he was
given and accidentally named the wrong
winner when he started to explain the
audience thought he was kidding at first
but he clarified that this was no joke
the actual winner was Miss Philippines
it was a fiasco worthy of an animated
sitcom but given that this was happening
in the real world everyone involved
found it up a whole lot less funny check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]